thank you
my exclusive conversation with former
president Obama touched on a lot of big
issues facing the country but we also
got personal
we had your wife Michelle on the show
and she had mentioned that for about 10
years of the marriage she really didn't
like you oh man um so asking for a
friend how do you get back in good
graces again for a friend you got a
pants off taking notes let me just say
this uh it sure helps to be out of the
White House
and to have a little more time with her
right you know what also helps though
about children and I don't know about
your spouse
Michelle
when when our girls were growing up
that was priority number one two
three and four of course and so I I did
not fully appreciate I think as as
engaged of a father as I was
the degree of stress and tension for her
knowing that not just me and Michelle
were under scrutiny and in this strange
environment but that we were raising our
daughters of course and and
a a kind of uh situation that it
just wasn't normal
now that they're doing good yeah
um you know she
is a little more forgiving about all my
flaws uh she she says you know what
she's told me is you know looking back
you did okay as a dad yeah and uh and
and if I pass that test then then uh
she'll forgive me most of my other my
other uh affordables
I love that answer number one he could
have easily laughed it off and joked
about it he's always very thoughtful as
is she yeah I thought it was great I
can't wait to see what else you do well
stick around we have more of the
exclusive conversation local news is
next